[Music]
well fairytale romances to come true
dancing stars max and Peeta are proof of
that and Cameron you have seen this this
love blossom personal it's nice I've
known max since 2007 what I did Dancing
with the Stars and I can say without a
doubt this is the happiest I have seen
him for sure last couple years since
they bring with Peeta so happy for those
guys and we got the scoop about their
big day straight from two insiders the
wedding planner
and bridesmaid Sharna Burgess husband
and wife I've never seen both of them
more in love and more happy than I been
that moment the day before Chartres was
actually in another wedding in Berlin
she flew in just in time to stand by
Peters side at Long Island's Oheka
Castle it is the most beautiful place on
earth I I hope there is some weight just
like it so I can get married former
Dancing with the Stars troupe member and
Peeta's bestie Nicole Villa Nets game
artists remain Ivana IDI wedding planner
so how did she end up in charge of the
big day I threw them a surprise
engagement party they went so well that
same day they were like you have to plan
our wedding
Nicole was with the couple every step of
the way from dress fittings to
last-minute emergencies max called me an
hour before he has to walk down the
aisle and says I don't have my couplings
so that was fantastic at the reception
there were some surprises Peter put
together a video of Max and their
six-month-old son shy and Max shocked
his new wife with a song
max his biggest fear is singing and so
he decided to overcome that in front of
everyone on his wedding day another
treat for the approximately 300 guests
there was a desert brew room my costumes
almost didn't fit me when I came back to
talk yeah I'm not worried about those
guys they can burn it off dancing
charters currently on the road with the
rest of the dancing pros but it took a
break the week of max and Peter's
wedding so people could attempt
[Music]
you